Ever since Edwin Hubble discovered
that the universe is expanding,
there has been a great debate
about the speed of this expansion,
also called The Hubble constant.
In 2000, scientists thought they had reached
a consensus: with a Hubble constant at about 72.
But since then, two methods of calculating
the expansion rate have gotten farther
and farther apart.
and some scientists think it’s too big of a difference
to just be a statistical fluke.
To calculate the Hubble constant,
we need both a velocity, and a distance.
Velocities are easy.
It requires measuring the Redshift of a galaxy
as it recedes.
But distances are much harder.
We need “standard candles”
-- objects that shine with an intrinsic brightness.
That way, its observed brightness
could be converted to a distance.
The first method used to calculate the Hubble constant,
originated with Hubble.
He started by measuring distances to nearby objects
and working his way out,
hence the name...
The first rung is within our Milky Way.
Here we measure the distances to Cepheids,
pulsating stars that have an intrinsic brightness.
Then we look to nearby galaxies that contain both
Cepheids and another type of standard candle,
Type 1A Supernovae.
These exploding white dwarf stars
also have an intrinsic brightness.
After calibrating these supernovae,
astronomers can then move out to a third rung,
to even more distant galaxies
that only contain supernovae.
Linking all these measurements, a recent study
has pinned the Hubble constant at 73.
Instead of starting within our galaxy and looking out,
the second method looks back in time
to almost the beginning of the universe.
Here we find the Cosmic Microwave Background:
the radiation leftover from the Big Bang.
The CMB’s subtle variations in temperature describe
changes in the density of the Universe
right after the big bang.
Instead of standard candles, physicists use
the size of the tiny fluctuations as standard yardsticks.
With these yardsticks, they can calculate what
the Hubble constant would be today.
Recent estimates are at about 68, significantly lower
than the cosmic distance ladder’s approach.
Both camps hope to resolve this debate
in the coming years with the help of
new telescopes and instruments.
But if the discrepancy in the Hubble constant remains,
it could mean that our understanding of
the expansion of the universe is missing an ingredient--
that something happened between
the big bang and the present.
Maybe there’s a neutrino out there
we haven’t discovered.
Maybe the mysterious force “dark energy,”
which makes up a significant portion of our universe,
can change in strength.
Or maybe subtle flaws in one or both approaches
to the Hubble Constant are giving us the wrong answer.